- [Narrator] Mexican
chilies used in Sriracha,
Italian Risotto rice,
American corn that's used
in just about everything,
these staple crops are all vulnerable
to hot weather and a lack of water.
And as many countries have been hit
by extreme droughts this year,
farmers are feeling the heat as yields
are a fraction of normal levels.
Italian rice farmers for example,
are expected to lose 30 to 50%
of their yields this year
as paddy fields dry up.
- When you have this hot weather
and drought this late of the year,
it really puts a lot of
stress on those plants
at a really key time in their growth.
And that's why some economists think
that their crop yield could be stressed,
and the yields could go down.
- [Narrator] And commodities analysts say
that those lower yields
could increase prices.
The string of droughts,
coupled with food and energy shortages,
and supply chain disruptions,
are expected to keep the cost
of staples high this winter.
Waterways that typically feed
the agricultural systems across the world
have been parched by drought this summer.
Italy's longest river, the river Po,
accounts for up to 40%
of the country's agricultural
production by market value.
But water levels have
dropped well below normal
in recent months.
(speaks foreign language)
In France, the country has faced
the most severe drought ever recorded.
And during China's driest
summer in six decades,
water levels plummeted in
parts of the Yangtze river,
a crucial life source for crops.
In the US, nearly 30% of corn production
is based in drought hit areas
as record high temperatures
have stifled parts of North America.
- It's been hot,
and hotter than normal.
And I think one of the key things
to remember about the heat,
while it's been bad in a lot of places,
it's exacerbating some drought
that was in existing parts of the US.
When you put that hot weather
on top of the drought,
that's what's really the key thing here.
It's the drought and the heat wave
that has just been so bad this summer.
And it's put a lot of stress on farmers.
- Our yields are off.
Our yields are probably off 25%.
- A lot of ranchers are havin'
to reduce or liquidate their herds.
- All these things compounding
could just be a decision
for a farmer to have to call it quits.
- Drought affect prices fast,
let's say, at local level.
So let's say, for tomatoes
other producer here in Italy,
so they will be more expensive.
If they have a,
let's say a reduction in the production,
but then in Europe at also global level,
we have this interconnection
in the markets.
And for this, we look mainly
to the bread bag, baskets
that are the countries
that produce most grain.
South America, central US,
Ukraine, India, also China.
- [Narrator] When a drought hits one
or more of these so-called bread baskets,
there's less supply of staple crops
in the global market.
And as a result, prices get pushed up.
This has happened before
during drought years like 2012,
and while prices are currently lower
than they were during March, 2022,
they are still historically high,
and are projected to go up even further
in the months ahead.
Wheat prices are expected to jump
by 20 to 30% this year,
according to research by JP Morgan.
Those changes in costs felt by customers
are being driven not only by drought,
but also by the war in Ukraine,
and continued pandemic related
supply chain disruptions.
But analysts say the
changing weather patterns
we're seeing this year,
will continue to influence
key agricultural markets
well beyond this summer.
Scientists have forecast
there will be an uptick in frequency,
and severity of droughts as
temperatures continue to rise.
And that means, economies are going
to have to brace themselves
as droughts can threaten
global food security.
(wind blows)